bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france alors
quelles sont les revendications de cette
mobilisation aujourd'hui oui non le
possible aussi que je suis l'union
nationale des retraités de la cftc
je peux shop été indiqué donc je
représente l'organisation cftc
alors aujourd'hui va le beaucoup de
points ont déjà été adoptées l'arrêt
indiqué par le votre précédent
intervenant aujourd'hui nous manifestons
donc l ensemble à l'appel de l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales de
retraités nous l'espérons pouvoir être
reçue au ministère pour avoir au moins
de l'information à peu près si ge
parce que bon aujourd'hui le toute façon
que ce soit les jeunes les salariés ou
les retraités tout le monde subit les
effets de la situation
vraiment je m'inscris dans
l'intersyndicale cftc dont ils
représentent les retraités cet essai
tout en travaillant au sein de
l'intersyndicale depuis plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années
nous travaillons ensemble si bien avec
la cgt fo fsu solidaires cgc elle nous
sommes en contact permanent à presque
chaque jour durant ce moment pour
essayer de faire évaluer évoluer les
dossiers et dire l'essentiel de que nous
retrouvions dit qu on vous l'avait dit à
un tiers de retraités reçoivent des
pensions mensuelles inférieur à 1000
euros
donc quand même se poser la question
aujourd'hui comment les gens peuvent
vivre avec 1000 euros 1 sachant que bon
sinon même qu'elle ait fait patrimoine
mais l'on est depuis longtemps
s'ils ont des loyers impayés même
retraités les communes payent des loyers
et ne restait plus grand chose pour
vivre très difficile de faire face au
coût de la vie
aujourd'hui pour ces personnes même ceux
qui ont un petit peu des patrimoines il
ya des grands qui met en avant les
retraités ont un peu de patrimoine
ils l'ont eu souvent un patrimoine un
moment
ils ont travaillé et dont arte leur
moyenne de leur lieu de vie bon souvent
si j'en avais eu des héritages des
personnes intérieur qui avait bien
peut-être moins d'argent que nous mais
qui avaient acheté des maisons et bon
bah maintenant je reviens tout me
revient trop faire même l'écart habituel
sont trop élevés je sois la nourriture
les frais de loyer les frais
d'électricité qui est mensonge aurait
tous les frais de journaliers augmente à
vincennes donc aujourd'hui nous espérons
donc nous allons nous rassembler à 14
heures devant le ministère de la santé
pour essayer d'obtenir des précisions
peu sur ce que nous attendons c'est à
dire une revalorisation des pensions qui
est nécessaire pour tous très tous les
niveaux
justement que pensez vous de cette
déclaration de bruno le maire qui
demande qui souhaite favoriser les
donations plutôt que l'épargné ils
demandent justement grands-parents de
soutenir allez les petits enfants est-ce
que cela vous paraît juste
les gens vivent chez longtemps
maintenant pour quand même profiter de
ce qu'ils ont acquis souvent ça se passe
les transactions se passe au niveau des
déchets des des personnages et auprès
des familles mais on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui enfin d'être conduit moyens
comme elle peut pour monsieur le
ministre qui peut-être le faire mais ça
m'étonnerait que les gens qui ont une
pension modeste depuis ce grade
envisager toutes les formules vous
parlais justement derval et
revalorisation des retraites
de la baisse aussi du pouvoir d'achat en
conséquence et aussi l'accès à la
vaccination ça c'est aussi une
revendication importante aujourd'hui
oui parce que moi je veux dire que
personnellement tout au début me suis
pas vraiment adapté au fait de me faire
vacciner
mais depuis donc j'ai quand même vu la
situation est d'ailleurs même si déjà
fait vacciner la livenne simplement je
suis donc la première réflexion de
vaccins et la seconde aura lieu le 22
avril
donc je me suis investie totalement pour
ce vaccin le conseil ou que les yachts
de faire diversion ça nous protégera je
pense quand même enfin mais j'espère
être protégés par ce mec là et que
pensez vous justement de cette campagne
de vaccination qui avance comme un
flottement les laumes mais ça dépend si
des endroits je pense que moi je peux
pas donner
mauvais exemple de parce que dans la
commune nouvelle demeure dans l'oeuf à
bon ben ça s'est très bien passé je suis
allé dans un endroit il fallait
s'inscrire social creed on va dîner tout
une date de vaccination et la g après la
première vaccination que déjà la date de
la machination
il semble que ça se passait bien y a pas
eu d'attentât pas eu de réclamations à
faire la mairie dépôt s'il avait bien
organisé c'est cette mesure est mise en
place en tout cas c'était très bien
organisé vous savez qu'il ya eu un
conseil de défense ce matin un conseil
des ministres qui se tient dans la
foulée et ce soir en attend l'allocution
du président de la république emmanuel
macron quelles sont vos attentes
moi je me demande bien qu'est ce qu'est
ce qui va nous annoncer monsieur macron
ce soir parce que veut pas du tout aidé
d'un seul coup elle n'intervient
régulièrement donc à la télévision
depuis un moment mais on nous retraités
on attend des mesures pour les retraités
on attendait me dire bien sûr pour les
gens qui sont victimes de cette maladie
de ce virus
quand même c'est le plus grave encore
que nous et on attend aussi des mesures
en faveur des retraités et des
variations de pension
on verrait une amélioration de la vie
des gens des retraités pour les lécher
mon attente comme ça pourtant je crois
que vous vous avez travaillé depuis
l'âge de 18 ans la mairie de paris en
tant que secrétaire médicale je vais pas
vous demander quelle est votre situation
mais est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que depuis le mandat des manuels macron
la situation a empiré pour les retraités
en france
moi je crois que la situation empire et
maintenant parce qu'on va trouver devant
des difficultés parce qu'il ya toujours
les use de toutes les guerres les
commandes les dépenses journalières
les dépenses obligatoires sur lesquels
lequel on peut passer pas chez cela vaut
pas comment la situation peut
s'améliorer
moi je ne peux pas me plaindre dans ma
situation je travaillais très longtemps
dans quelque 40 ans une retraite des
fonctionnaires de catégorie b dans la
fonction publique
qu'est ce qui correspond à la mairie de
paris donc je ne peux pas me plaindre
bon malheureusement j'ai perdu mon mari
est donc très mauvais pied m'enfin bon
ce rachat permet de vivre quand même
correctement
donc je parle et me plaindre pour les
mais il faut quand même entendre les
gens que vous les plus grosses
difficultés que les miennes merci miel
et son secondaire par rapport aux
difficultés rencontrées par vous même
pour les gens de tous les jours et les
gens qui ont commis le rôle de censeur
dit que s'il est bien plus grave c'est
bien plus grave
merci beaucoup à vous jacqueline velits
voudrait qu'on soutienne voilà ici voilà
messages en temps devant nous pour nos
retraites parce qu'on voudrait qu'après
nous y pas de belles des retraites et
des pensions de tout le monde merci à
vous en tout cas jacqueline va dit je
rappelle que vous êtes présidente de
lun'art l'union nationale des retraités
pour la cftc je le précise merci